AND CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS
WILL COME TO ORDER. GOOD
MORNING IN RESPONSE TO THE COVE
IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND A
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. HOLDENER COMMITTEE
HEARING IN THE CAPITOL BUILDING
TODAY. WE ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WITH ADMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS. TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOWING WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE EIGHT NINE. THE ACCESS CODE
IS TWO EIGHT SEVEN SIX ZERO
FIVE NINE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE. AND OR-
AND OR ARE COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
WHEN WE MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT TO
BE PROMPTED BY THE UNMODERATED
TO DIAL ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. PRESSES
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU TO A LINE NUMBER
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
pYOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU WILL
BE ON MUTE IT AND YOU'RE NOT
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEDIAN SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WELL EVERY
EFFORT IS MADE TO STREAMLINE
THE HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCT
OUR HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE. TO
THE SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY
THERE MAY BE SOME LIKE TIMES
FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE ONLINE
TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL AND PATIENTS OF
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. WE HAVE ONLY ONE BILL ON
TODAY'S AGENDA SB FIVE NINE
FOUR. BY GLAZER WE WILL NOT BE
HEARING SB THIRTY FIVE BY
SENATOR AMBERGATE ARE HEARING
TODAY. THE BILL WAS NOTICE FOR
TODAY'S HEARING PENDING RECEIPT
FROM THE ASSEMBLY. HOWEVER THE
BILL HAS NOT YET BEEN TAKEN UP
ON THE FLOOR OR PASSED BY THE
ASSEMBLY. SO WE ARE NOT IN
RECEIPT OF THAT BILL AGAIN
THAT'S SB THIRTY FIVE IF YOU
WERE. HAVE BEEN WAITING
PATIENTLY TO TESTIFY ON THAT MY
APOLOGIES TO YOU WILL NEED TO
WAIT UNTIL THAT BILL. GETS OUT
OF THE ASSEMBLY. BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATIONS ON- SB FIVE NINE
FOUR LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM
CONSOLE WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. GLAZER HERE GLAZER
HERE NIELSEN. HERTZBERG YEAH
HERTZBERG HERE LEYVA YOUR LIVER
HERE NEWMAN. OKAY WE HAVE WE
HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM.
NEWMAN GOOD MORNING. AT THE
CENTER OF NEWMAN IS HERE ALSO
LET ME MENTION FOR THE RECORD
THAT CENTER NIELSEN'S OUR VICE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE HE
UNFORTUNATELY HAD A CONFLICT
THIS MORNING I ASKED HIM IF HE
WOULD PREFER THAT WE- DELAY
THIS YEAR IN FOR ANOTHER DAY OR
TIME TO BE CONVENIENT FOR HIM
HE INDICATED THAT NO HE WAS
COMFORTABLE WITH THE HEARING-
GOING FORWARD SO I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT'S NOTED. ON THE
RECORD. ALL RIGHT SO WE HAVE
ONE BILL ON THE HEARING DOCKET
I AM THE AUTHOR OF THAT BILL.
SO I THINK I'VE ARRANGED IN
ADVANCE TO TURN THE MATTER OVER
TO- SENATOR NEWMAN TO- CHAIR-
THE HEARING AT THIS POINT IN
TIME. SO WHILE DURING THE GAVEL
OVER TO SENATOR NEWMAN. SURE.
YEAH THANK YOU MR GLAD TO HELP-
AND SO WE ARE NO GOING TO HEAR
SB FIVE NINE FOUR- AND PLEASE
THE SENATE GLAZER PLEASE
PRESENT. OKAY THAT'S OKAY TO
PRESENT FROM MY CHAIR MISTER
SHERMAN FOR SISTER. I'M GONNA
MAKE AN EXCEPTION TODAY
CENTIGRADE YES. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT I'VE REALIZED THIS YEAR
MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
THE SB FIVE NINETY FOUR AS YOU
KNOW DUE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC THE RELEASE OF CENSUS
DATA WAS SIGNIFICANTLY DELAYED
THE CYCLE. WHICH THAT THE
SUPREME COURT TO MOVE BACK THE
DEADLINE FOR STATE AND
CONGRESSIONAL REDISTRICTING BY
SEVERAL MONTHS. DIGITAL
DEADLINE WAS AUGUST FIFTEENTH
OF THIS YEAR. THE NEW DEADLINE
IS NOT FULLY SETTLED AND WILL
LIKELY BE CLARIFIED BY THE
SUPREME COURT. BUT MOST LIKELY
BE SOMETIME BETWEEN LATE
DECEMBER OF THIS YEAR AND IN
JANUARY OF NEXT YEAR. AS A
RESULT OF THIS EXTENSION THE
ELECTIONS CALENDAR LEADING UP
TO THE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
PRIMARY NEEDS TO BE ADJUSTED.
TO RECONCILE THE REDISTRICTING
TIMELINE WITH THE CANDIDATE
FILING TIMELINE. TEND TO
PROVIDE ELECTIONS OFFICIALS
WITH TIME TO RE PRECEPT. SB
FIVE NINETY FOUR ACCOMPLISHES
THIS BY AMONG OTHER
ADJUSTMENTS. SHORTENING THE
PERIOD FOR COLLECTING
SIGNATURES IN LIEU. OF PAYING A
FILING FEE. AND POTENTIALLY
ALSO SHORTENING THE TIME PERIOD
FOR FILING NOMINATION
DOCUMENTS. DEPENDING ON HOW
LATE THE SUPREME COURT SETS THE
STATE REDISTRICTING DEADLINE.
TO ACCOUNT FOR THIS ABBREVIATED
TIMELINE THIS BILL REDUCES THE
NASCENT THE NUMBER OF NECESSARY
SIGNATURE TO SIGNATURE IN LIEU.
IN PROPORTION TO THE REDUCTION
IN TIME. AND ALSO GIVES
CANDIDATES FOR BOARD OF A THE
CAUSATION OR THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. THE FLEXIBILITY TO
ESTABLISH DISTRICT DISTRICT
RESIDENCY AT THE TIME
NOMINATION PAPERS ARE FILED
INSTEAD OF WHEN THEY'RE PULLED.
SB FIVE NINETY FOUR ALSO MAKES
A NUMBER OF IMPORTANT CHANGES
THE LOCAL REDISTRICTING PROCESS
INCLUDING. ERECTING POTENTIAL
AMBIGUITIES IN STATE LAW THAT
MIGHT OTHERWISE REQUIRE A LOCAL
MATCH TO BE APPROVED MORE THAN
A MONTH EARLIER THAN WAS
INTENDED. AND TO CREATING A
MORE UNIFORM DEADLINE FOR
SPECIAL DISTRICT READ
REDISTRICTING. THAT ALSO
ELIMINATES AN UNNECESSARILY
EARLY DEADLINE FOR CERTAIN
SPECIAL DISTRICTS. THESE
CHANGES PROVIDE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITH MORE
FLEXIBILITY AND TIME. TO
DELIBERATE. WHILE PRESERVING
TIME FOR ELECTION OFFICIALS TO
IMPLEMENT THE NEW LINES. SB
FIVE NINETY FOUR RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE ASSEMBLY WANT TO. EXPRESS
MY APPRECIATION TO THE
EXCEPTIONAL STAFF HERE IN THE
SENATE ELECTIONS COMMITTEE AND
IN THE ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE. LEADERSHIP AND
AMBLESIDE BOTH HOUSES AND BOTH
SIDES AS WELL AS THE
ADMINISTRATION AND PUTTING THIS
BILL TOGETHER AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE.
I HAVE WITH ME SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY REGISTRAR. TRICIA WEBER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF CLICK CLERKS. AND ELECTIONS.
THEY DO NOT HAVE A FORMAL
POSITION ON THE BILL BUT MISS
WEBER WILL CAN SPEAK TO SOME OF
THE PROVISIONS THAT THE
ASSOCIATION CONSIDERS
IMPORTANT. FOR ELECTIONS
ADMINISTRATION. AND I'M ALSO
JOINED BY JEAN HURST
REPRESENTING URBAN COUNTIES OF
pOF THE BILL THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU THE
SENATOR GLAZERS LET LET'S
BEGIN. TO SMITE WITH MISS WEBER
MISSED WEBER YOU'LL HAVE TWO
MINUTES FOR YOUR TESTIMONY EACH
OF THE WITNESS WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES- WE WILL HAVE TWENTY
MINUTES TOTAL- OF FOUR INPUT
HERE FOR PER FOR WITNESSES PLUS
PUBLIC COMMENT- MR EVERSLEY
BEGIN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN SENATOR GLAZER AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS TRICIA WEBER AND I'M
THE SANTA CRUZ COUNTY CLERK
REGISTRAR OF VOTERS AND THE CO
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS AND
ELECTION OFFICIALS LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE. WALLER COMMITTEE IS
EITHER IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL
NINETY. WE ARE ASKED TO SPEAK
TO THE NECESSARY ASPECT OF THE
BILL AND THE ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. AS YOU KNOW THE PANDEMIC
CAUSED CENTER STATED DELAYS AND
THOSE DELAYS HAVE HAD A DIRECT
IMPACT ON THE UPCOMING
REDISTRICTING PROCESS. ELECTION
OFFICIALS RECOGNIZE THAT
CHANGES IN STATE LAW ARE
REQUIRED TO CONDUCT THE
SUCCESSFUL PRIMARY ELECTION IN
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND SB
FIVE NINETY FOR HELP WITH THE
SITUATION. FIRST OFF THE BILL
OF MINE TO DATE FOR CERTAIN
SPECIAL DISTRICTS TO SUBMIT
THEIR DISTRICT LINES TO THE
ELECTION OFFICIAL WHILE
MAINTAINING THE DATE FOR
COUNTIES TO SUBMIT THEIR BOARD
OF SUPERVISOR LINE. WILL HELP
LOCAL OFFICIALS TO ENSURE THAT
THEY HAVE THE DATA MAPS AND
EQUIVALENCY FILED IN A MANNER
THAT IS USABLE SO ONCE THEY
RECEIVE THE STATE LINES THEY
WILL BE READY TO START THE
REPRESSED CREASING TEAM PROCESS.
NEXT SB FIVE NINETY FOUR
ADDRESSES THE START DATE FOR
THE SIGNATURE IN LIEU
COLLECTION PERIOD WHICH IS THE
FIRST ACTIVITY A CANDIDATE MAY
UNDERTAKE AND THEIR RUN FOR AN
ELECTION OUR PRIMARY ELECTION
OFFICE. WITHOUT A CHANGE IN
STATE LAW THE SIGNATURE IN LIEU
PERIOD INSTEAD TO START ON
DECEMBER SIXTEENTH HOWEVER THE
SOONEST YOU CAN QUESTION ON
STATE LEGISLATIVE DISTRICT
LINES WILL BE FINALIZED IN
DECEMBER TWENTY SEVENTH.
CAUSING ELECTION OFFICIALS TO
ISSUE SIGNATURE IN LIEU
DOCUMENTS TO PEOPLE WHOSE
DISTRICT ARE UNKNOWN OR SOME
CANDIDATES WILL HAVE MORE TIME
TO COLLECT SIGNATURES THAN
OTHERS WHICH IS A DISPARITIES
FRIEDMAN. UNFORTUNATELY COULD
POSSIBLY FINALIZED AS LATE AS
JANUARY FOURTEENTH IT'S AN ILL
CONCEIVED EXPANSION REQUESTED
BY THE CITIZENS REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION IS GRANTED BY THE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT. SB FIVE NINETY FOUR
ADDRESSES THIS PROBLEM BY
SETTING THE DATE FOR
SIGNIFICANTLY COLLECTION TO
BEGIN SEVEN DAYS AFTER WHATEVER
THE STATE STATE REDISTRICTING
DEADLINE ENDS UP BEING.
SENSIBLE WAITING A FIXED DATE
TIED TO JANUARY FOURTEENTH
WHICH WERE ARTIFICIALLY
TRUNCATE THIS IMPORTANT PROCESS
IF THE COURT RULES FOR AN
EARLIER DATE. IN A SIMILAR
MANNER THIS BILL CHANGES THE
END DATE OF THE SIGNATURE AND
LITTLE PERIOD AND THE BEGINNING
DATE OF THE CANDIDATE
NOMINATION PERIOD FROM SIX
STATES STEP BY LAW. THE FORTY
ONE DAYS IN FORTY SIX STATES
RESPECTIVELY AFTER THE STATE
REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I GUESS YOU PLEASE COMPLETE
YOUR TESTIMONY THANK YOU SO
MUCH. OKAY FINALLY THIS BILL
DOES NOT MAIL THE LAST DAY TO
COMPLETE CANDIDATE FILING WHICH
IS SET BY WIDE EIGHTY EIGHT
DAYS BEFORE ELECTION DAY OR
EIGHTY THREE DAYS BEFORE
ELECTION DAY IF AN INCUMBENT
FAILED TO FILE FOR OFFICE. THIS
IS A CRITICAL FEATURE OF THE
BILL AS AN EXTENSION OF THESE
DEADLINE HAS MAJOR DOWNSTREAM
EFFECTS WHAT OTHER ELECTION
DUTIES THAT CANNOT BE
SUFFICIENTLY MAPPED OUT WHAT
WE'RE ATTEMPTING TO CONDUCT.
THE CURRENT RECALL ELECTION.
REGISTERS ARE STILL CONCERNED
THAT WE WILL NOT HAVE ENOUGH
TIME TO ADEQUATELY IMPORTANT
PROOF THE REDISTRICTING DATA
THAT WE MAKE IT AS LATE AS
JANUARY FOURTEENTH. HOWEVER SB
FIVE NINETY FOUR PROVIDES
FLEXIBILITY WITH THE EARLIEST
DEADLINES AND MAINTAINS THE
MOST CRUCIAL DEADLINE FOR
CANDIDATE FILINGS. THANK YOU
AND I'M AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY SO. THAT
NEXT. WE HAVE IN THIS FIRST AND
LET ME JUST NOTE THAT. WE WILL
BE GIVING OPPOSITION AND
SUPPORT EQUAL TIME SO IF YOU
THREE MINUTES SO FAR- MEASURES
IF YOU COULD KEEP YOUR COMMENTS
TO TWO MINUTES. OR SO
APPRECIATED PLEASE PROCEED.
ABSOLUTELY MISS CARE. GENE
HEARST- CALLING IN TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE- URBAN COUNTIES
OF CALIFORNIA- ALSO
REPRESENTING THAT RIVERSIDE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL TODAY-
URBAN COUNTIES JUST WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR- APPRECIATION AS A
CENTER GLAZER DID WITH- BOTH
THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE
ELECTION COMMITTEES LEADERSHIP
STAFF. AND THE ADMINISTRATION-
FOR THEIR- SUPPORT. AND
DIALOGUE- DURING WHAT HAS BEEN
A REALLY UNCERTAIN TIME- WITH
REGARDS TO REDISTRICTING. A WE
ARE SPECIFICALLY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE PROVISION- IN SB FIVE
NINETY FOUR THAT CLEAR FI'S-
THE REQUIREMENT. FOR COUNTIES
TO ADOPT A BIRD IS A REAL
DISTRICT BOUNDARIES. EITHER BY
ORDINANCE OR RESOLUTION ALLOWS
US TO DO THAT AND TIMELY WAY WE-
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB FIVE
NINE FOUR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND TAKE ESPECIALLY FOR BEING
SOBER. SO LET US NOW BEGIN WITH
ANY WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE TO WITH ME
WITNESSES HEARD TESTIFYING
FORTY THREE SEEING NONE. LET US
NOW LOOK TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
AS ANYBODY WHO WISHES TO JUST
ONE PERSON ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
THAT MEMBERS OF. THE C. SEEING
NONE WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROP INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE NINE FOUR WE WILL BEGIN
AND AS WE BEGIN TO BE CLEAR
THAT TESTIMONY HERE. IS IF YOU
COULD PLEASE GIVE YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION YOUR POSITION.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THE PHONE LINES IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO EIGHTEEN
KIDNAPPERS GONNA GO AND GIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER OFFLINE AND
THEN PLACE IT BACK IN THE
QUEUE. IN FOR- TESTIFY PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
WE'RE TAKING BOTH OF SUPPORT
AND- OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME
MISTER CHAIR WE'RE TAKING
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME POTTER
THANK YOU. OKAY KELOID AT THAT
SUPPORT ONLY. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY
NINE. BY TWENTY NINE PLEASE
TRANSPARENT THIS PROCESS IS NOT
TRANSPARENT PEOPLE ARE WAITING
ON THE LINE FOR SB THIRTY FIVE.
I THANK YOU UNTIL NOW- BUT TO
ALL COLORS LET ME REMIND YOU WE
WOULD LIKE YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION- AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL THANK YOU.
AGUIAR-CURRY YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD THIRTY HI MY NAME IS
VERONICA AND RESIDENT HAS
MARYSVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I'M
CALLING FOR- OPPOSITION SB
THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU RECALL
MR MODERATOR LOOK LET US LIMIT
CARD THESE CALLS TO FIRST
SUPPORT NOW AND THEN WILL TAKE
TESTIMONY FROM POSITION AND
WILL TAKE TELECONFERENCE
OPPOSITION FOLLOWING THAT. OKAY
LADIES GENTLEMAN PER OPPOSITION
IF YOU ARE TESTIFYING
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS THE ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN TO TAKE
YOURSELF OUT OF THE QUEUE AND
WE WILL REPRISE YOU'LL- IN JUST
SHORTLY AFTER WE GET THROUGH
THE- AND- AND LET ME ALSO NOTE
FOR BETTY CALLERS WAITING TO
TESTIFY. SB THIRTY FIVE WHICH
WAS ORIGINALLY COUNTER HAS BEEN
REMOVED FROM THE COUNTER IT
WILL HAVE A HEARING AT SOME
LATER DATE BUT IT'S NOT PART OF
TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS. WE ARE I.
SB FIVE NINE FOUR SO PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO OR
SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE NINE FOUR
NINE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWENTY EIGHT HELLO. THE FACT
THAT- MORNING ARE YOU. WHAT ARE
YOU DOING- SILVA CALL TO STATE
YOUR NAME WITHOUT YOUR
AFFILIATION YOUR POSITION
PLEDGE. YES I AM- IT'S WEIRD I
CAN HEAR ALL KIND OTHER NOISES
GOING ON THE BACKGROUND- AND I
AM STRONG OPPOSITION. FROM ON
JUST LAW THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CALL LET ME REITERATE THAT THIS
THIS PART OF THE PROCEEDINGS
FOR CALLERS YOU'RE CALLING IN
SUPPORT- WE WILL GET TO
OPPOSITION WHEN WE GET TO
OPPOSITION. MYSTERY PLEASE. AS
CHAIR SAID PLEASE A PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION SO IT'S IN
SUPPORT MISS MODERATE WE'RE
DOING SUPPORT FIRST. RIGHT I
WAS JUST LETTING PEOPLE
OPPOSITION PRITCHETT THAT'LL
TAKE THEMSELVES OUT YOU. AND
THEN WE'LL GO TO. TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GOOD MORNING PAUL YOUR
ON BEHALF OF THE PLEASURE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT OF THE GLAZER BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS YOUR.
BY TWENTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING SHARING COMMITTEE
THIRTY CAT ON BEHALF OF THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
FINAL EVAN YOU ARE NOW OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
JULIA HALL WITH UTILIZATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU. BY
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING JEFF NEAL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT. AND AS A FINAL
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND
LINE TWENTY TWO EUROPE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU AND GOOD
MORNING I'M NOT SURE MEMBERS
ANTHONY PANEL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL FIVE
NINE FOUR. THANK YOU MISTER
CARE WE HAVE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME SIR M. IS BETTER IF YOU
JUST MAKE ONE MORE PASS THROUGH
THIS ANYBODY CALLING SUPPORT BE
GRATEFUL. ABSOLUTELY AS A FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. AND WE
DO HAVE ONE QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY
FOUR YOUR OPEN UP THEY TOOK
THEMSELVES OUT. TWENTY FOUR IF
YOU'D LIKE TO TRY AGAIN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND THEY'RE
BACK GO AHEAD TWENTY FOUR. YEAH
I DROPPED LIKE THREE TIMES SO
YOUR SYSTEM IS NOT WORKING I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB FIVE NINE
FOUR WE TAKE OUR CALL THIS IS
NOT RIGHT WHAT YOU'RE DOING
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CALL WE ARE
ACTUALLY IN THE PORTION OF THE
PROCEEDINGS FOR SUPPORT WE WILL
BE MOVING ON TO OPPOSITION
EXPRESSED MODERATE OR TO ANY
OTHER CALLS IN SUPPORT. NO NOT
AT THIS TIME MISTER CARE. THANK
YOU MISS MODERATION WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION- THE
SUPPORT SIDE WAS GIVEN BY
PRESSING FOR MINUTES FOR THE
TESTIMONY WE WILL ALLOW FOR UP
TO TWO SPEAKERS UP TO FOUR
MINUTES IN OPPOSITION. AS
ANYBODY WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION THE BILL. NOW IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. LET ME FIRST
CHECK THE ROOM AT SITTING FORTY
TWO THREE SIXTEEN NO ONE. AT
MOVING TO THE OVERFLOW WITH ANY
WITNESSES IN TWENTY FORTY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION SB. FIVE NINETY FOUR.
TWO NINE WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
THE WITNESSES WILLING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE WITH
LIKE TWENTY SIX EUROPE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE ON MUTE. AND
WE'RE WILLING TO DO YOU CAN
HAVE UP TO TWO MINUTES. TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. YEAH
OPPOSABLE- ERICA WALKER
SACRAMENTO COUNTY STRONGLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU NEXT. THIRTY
ONE. OKAY TO FIND THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEATHER KELLER
SACRAMENTO COUNTY STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB FIVE NINE FOUR.
THANK YOU NEXT. THANK YOU I
TWENTY THREE YOU ARE OPEN. MIKE
JOSEPH- I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
WE'RE MOVING FORWARD WITH- ANY
BILLS AT THIS POINT BECAUSE
THIS IS A KOBE AND NIGHTMARES
SO WE'RE TRYING TO DO
REDISTRICTING IS IN THE MIDDLE
OF SOME KIND OF STORM OF- THE
DISEASE. PREVENTING EVERYONE
FROM EVEN BEING ON THESE CALLS
ARE BEING AT THE CAPITOL TO
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON. AND YOU
GUYS ARE MOVING FORWARD TRYING
TO RE DISTRICT AND THEN PUSHING
IT OUT TO PASS THE ELECTION
DATE AND IT'S JUST A VERY
BIZARRE SYSTEM YOU HAVE RUNNING
HERE. AND I HOPE THAT YOU'LL
CONSIDER- STOPPING LEGISLATING.
INSTEAD OF CONTINUING ON WE
DON'T NEED ANYMORE BILLS
ESPECIALLY BILLS WITH THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA DO NOT
KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT. SO I AM
FULLY AGAINST ALL BILLS THAT
ARE COMING OUT OF THIS CAPITAL
AT THIS. CURRENT MOMENT. AND I
APPRECIATE YOU GUYS TRYING TO.
YOU WHAT YOU THINK IS RIGHT BUT-
NOBODY IN CALIFORNIA KNOWS WHAT
IS GOING ON WITH THESE BILLS.
PEOPLE ARE CALLING IN FOR OTHER
BUILDING BEING HUNG UP ON. THIS
IS NOT HOW A REPRESENTATIVE
GOVERNMENT WORKS SO I REALLY
LIKED. YOU GUYS THEY REALLY
CONSIDER THIS. THAT THERE IS NO
NEED FOR ANY MORE BILLS THAT
HAVE NOTHING TO DO. WITH THE
CURRENT SITUATION WHERE IT FOR
SUCH A SHUTDOWN STATE THE MUCH
DOWN STOP WASTING THE TAXPAYERS
MONEY. SYSTEMS THAT DON'T WORK
I APPRECIATE YOU GUYS OUT OF
YOUR DAY. AND I'M AGAINST THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY- WE HAVE ROOM
FOR ONE MORE WITNESS FROM
ACTUAL TO MANAGEMENT MODERATE
PLEASE. THANK YOU- WE WILL GO
TO LINE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S DIANA FROM
PLASTER COUNTY I STRONGLY
OPPOSED. SB FIVE NINETY FOUR.
IN ALL OTHER BILLS THAT YOU
GUYS DO THANK YOU HAVE A NICE
DAY. THANK THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CALL THAT MEANS MODERATE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO- THE REST THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY- ANY ANYBODY
WAITING IN LINE TO TESTIFY- WE
WOULD ASK THAT YOU STATE YOUR
NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION AND
YOUR POSITION. OKAY ONE
THIRTEEN YOU ARE OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME'S KATHERINE.
NEXT NEXT POST MODERN FIND
TWENTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD TWENTY EIGHT.
EVERY LAW ON JUST THE
CONSTITUTION IS NULL AND VOID
WITH THAT SAID STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE NINE FOUR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CALL. NEXT
CALL. EIGHT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LINE EIGHTEEN YOU ARE
OPEN. SH HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
WE CAN. OKAY I ASKED MY NAME IS
NICOLE YOUNG I'M FROM PLASTER
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB FIVE NINE FOUR AND I%
ACTUALLY STRONGLY OPPOSED THIS
WHOLE PROCESS BECAUSE YOU KEPT
PUBLIC OUT OF. THE PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU DON'T WAIT AND ARE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CALL I GUESS
IT'S IRONIC TO DO THIS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CALL WILL MOVE ON-
WE DO HAVE ONE QUEUING UP WITH
AN OPERATOR. ONE MOMENT.
ANYBODY ELSE ONE FILED BY ZERO
TO SHOW OPPOSITION. STRUCTURE
WE WILL GO TO LINE FIFTEEN YOU
ARE OPEN FIFTEEN. MY NAME THEIR
ADMISSIBILITY AND RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB. FIVE NINETY ONE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COSTS THEM MODERATE
ANY OTHER CALL AND WE'RE AT.
FOR WITNESSES TO IDENTIFY
THEMSELVES BY NAME AFFILIATION
THEIR POSITION ONLY. WE HAVE
ONE QUEUING UP JUST ONE MOMENT
PLEASE BY THEIR GET THEIR LINE
NUMBER. ANY SECOND AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NEWMAN DON'T
UNDERESTIMATE THE PEOPLE YOU
HAVE AND WE ARE Y. USED TO YOU
THIS PROP. THANK YOU MISS
HEDSTROM NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT MISS
MODERATE IF YOU COULD ASK ONE
MORE TIME FOR NEW CALLERS NEW
CALLERS ONLY IN OPPOSITION- ONE
LAST TIME THANK YOU. CHAU
OPPOSITION FOR- SB FIVE NINE
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE NO
PARTICIPANT SKEOCH SKEWS ME WE
JUST HAD ANOTHER ONE QUEUE UP
AND OPALEYE. TWENTY THREE. I
JUST WANT TO GET BACK IN HERE
THAT WAS- UNACCEPTABLE THAT YOU
GUYS ARE CUTTING PEOPLE OFF
WHEN THEY'RE TRYING TO SPEAK
ENGLISH MODERATE IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND THANK YOU SO.
THAT AND SHOULD HAVE A
TESTIMONY LET ME ALSO JUST
REITERATE WE HAVE A PROCESS
THAT PROCESS IS QUITE PUBLIC
AND EXPLICIT AFTER CONDUCTING
THESE HEARINGS DURING THE
PANDEMIC- AND WE'VE INSPIRED TO
THE EXTENT POSSIBLE TO MAKE.
ROOM AND FIND AT BAND AND
ACCOMMODATE PUBLIC TESTIMONY SO
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE
THIS IS NO DIFFERENT THAN- WHAT
WE'VE DONE THROUGHOUT THE
LEGISLATURE HERE IT IS
UNFORTUNATE BUT IT IS
NECESSARY. THANK YOU TO ALL OUR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WE WILL NOW BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE MEMBERS
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
CALAMOS FROM CENTER LET. TO
MOVE THE BILL- WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE EMIGRATE THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN THE BILL TRIED TO
RESPOND TO CIRCUMSTANCES OUT OF
OUR CONTROL AND BE AS CALM AS
WE CAN FOR CLERKS AND
REGISTRARS IN CANDIDATES AND
WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY
ASTRONOMICAL. THANK YOU
SYMPTOMS CLERK IF YOU COULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB FIVE
NINE FOUR GLAZER THE MOTION IS
THAT THE ASSEMBLY MOMENT
SPEAKING CARD AND- GLAZER. HI
THERE I NIELSEN. HERTZBERG HI
RICHARD I LEYVA HI RIVERSIDE
NEWMAN RIGHT HI. I DON'T KNOW
PASS IT BACK OVER TO THE CHAIR
SENATOR GLAZERS CHEERS YOURS.
THANK YOU AT THE STERN SENATOR
NEWMAN APPRECIATE OVER THE
CHAIRMANSHIP FOR THIS- ONE BILL
HEARING. I WANT TO THANK ALL
THE- INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED HEARING TODAY IF
YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
WELCOME TO SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS
OR SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO
THE COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS OR
VISIT OUR- WEBSITE. YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD THANK
YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION I THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR JOINING ME
TODAY. WE'VE CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS. IS ADJOURNED.